remember this the situation is very very
tough indeed in the nhs
they really are fighting very very hard
to contain this
pandemic they've been working flat out
and i think the strain is
is colossal through the pandemic nhs
workers were called heroes
all right thank you but it's also been
the worst year of kate baker's
18-year career i've never seen anything
like it
and that's not what you come into the
nhs to be part of you know you're going
to see
unwell people you know that people are
going to die
but not in the volumes that we've seen
and every time i go in i think gosh i'm
i'm doing this to try and keep my family
safe and to keep my
friends families safe so that's that's
why we do it
because i don't want to come into work
one day and to be my parents in that bed
because the odds aren't good and we know
that and we've seen it
so when you hear that you will be
getting a one percent pay rise how does
that make you feel
when you're seeing things we've seen
every day and to come up with one
percent when
actually all politicians have been
supposedly thanking us for
work it really feels like a kick in the
teeth for kate
a one percent pay rise equals around an
extra three pounds 50 a week
the union unite call it a disgrace
one that could lead to strikes i hope it
doesn't get to that stage but all
options are on the table and
you know we're not going to rule
anything out we're a long way from that
but obviously we're going to look at
every possible option and still going to
be campaigning
and urging the government to change
course and give
nhs workers as well as all other public
sector workers a proper pay rise this
year
unions want at least a 10 percent pay
rise but the government
say their offer is all they can afford
we do have issues of
the affordability because of the
consequences of the pandemic on the
public finances
which were set out in the budget this
week
and we have to take those into account
but we have been able to carve out the
nhs
from the pay freeze that applies
to everybody else billions have gone on
supporting people and businesses through
the pandemic but the nhs
is for many an emotional subject it's
funding even more so i'd love to see
them get three four five fifteen percent
wage rise
you know but they've got a job the way
the government is issuing a lot of help
to people like me
and various other you know
establishments like
all the ones that are closed i think
they're possibly doing all they can
they've proved how vital they are the
nhs has proved how vital they
are so it's it's quite disgusting this
particular hospital saved boris
johnson's life and that's how he's
rewarding them
unions say this is not over they will
fight for nhs staff
for what they think is fair catherine of
the toxic sky news